on Thursday our coverage kicks off this  afternoon at 3:30  we've put together a half hour special  on Allegiant Stadium the Raiders new  home  will cover the groundbreaking where we  stand today and how the latest world  events have played a role in all of this  again it's today at 3:30 right here on 8  news now all right it 650 this point my  gift for you it'll be quieter dog toys I  mean it's not as bad but I come here  show everybody okay this actually is  from a viewer  we call this mousie and it's it's mostly  intact it still has its ears and stuff  it's from a JR so thank you for that jr.  but yes you know when Bodie decides to  wake up and play we all get to  participate